hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this tuesday video we're gonna be
finishing up
my r shiny series with some dashboard
optimization
so when we're creating our dashboards um
i've kind of gone through like
different ways to create them different
ways to develop them with like modules
um how to add things into it how to do
basic filtering
but one of the things we have to think
about after we create like a minimal
viable product
is how can we improve the actual
operation of the dashboard
so this is one of the dashboards i
created in
my previous videos it's just a simple
ufc dashboard
where we can like change the weight
class um
you know so we can do like heavyweight
class we can see kind of like a time
series of all the fighters and their
elo with all the top fighters from the
um from that weight class
see a little table of you know the
top ranked fighters of all time we also
have
the distribution of the ego scores and
we can change it
with this k slider which adjusts the
sensitivity
of a of the evo formula
additionally we have a head-to-head
[Music]
model which uses the elo scores to
estimate the probability of each fighter
winning
um so we can do that change the eo
models parameters
also change the weight class um to like
you know like heavyweight
and that'll filter out all the available
fighters in that class
um stuff like that um
and it's a pretty cool dashboard um when
i created it i thought
it was pretty interesting it was a good
way to highlight different techniques
you know we have our filtering we have
like a little model into it we have some
cool little visuals
we have some interactive filtering too
with some
ui outputs stuff like that but um if we
actually kind of think about and look at
the actual dashboard it's a pretty um
rough
dashboard um there's a lot of ideas that
i didn't really
think about specifically um with the
actual speed and
you know render configurations so if we
actually look at this
um we can we can see that there's a lot
of
um reused stuff so i use the create elo
data
a lot where it's a function that uses my
existing data frame to run this eo model
combine all the ego stuff um and then
output an actual data frame
and if you think about it when we're
always when we're switching all the tabs
and stuff
uh it's gonna be constantly um running
that function
and you know with this data set because
it's not very large i think it's like a
2000 row data set
it doesn't really matter but you know
when you're working with like databases
with you know terabytes of data
thousands of users or hundreds of
analysts looking at it you can see how
we want to make it faster and more
efficient so that way it doesn't crash
or cause any issues
and that way we can actually improve the
user's experience you know because if
the if it's a laggy dashboard
no one's going to use it and that's
really bad especially if we
spend a lot of time creating it um it's
kind of a waste of time for all of us
so right now i'm just going to kind of
go through this and kind of explain what
we can do
to make this dashboard a little bit more
faster
and just some simple concepts that we
can do to speed it up
so first one of the biggest problems we
can think about is we don't want to
always call this function right so we
don't want to constantly create a new
data frame
run this elo model um and then combine
all the outputs from it
right um and if we think about it from
just like our use case for this
dashboard
we're essentially creating this elo data
um
whenever we change our uh our k
parameter
or the elo model which is like the
sensitivity criteria
and one thing that we should always
think about is when we're running this
type of dashboard or just dashboards in
general or even model pipelines is that
we really want to do all of the
computational
work um beforehand right so if we can
kind of like pre-run it or kind of like
uh preheat essentially on this data
um it'll make it faster so we don't have
to do so many uh transformations to it
so right here since we're doing this
function right here is essentially
creating our ego data
for a given k value um what we can do is
actually just kind of
re uh pre-run this data so in this
example
i just create loaded in our data frames
i loaded in the function i wrote
and then what i essentially did was i
chose you know some k values
that would be most useful for a real
application
and then just ran the function to
generate um a data set for
all five of these k values and
and then i export it out so if we look
at our elo data
we can see you know it's it's
essentially the same thing
but we have this little um k column
which will show us all of our k values
for or which will basically correspond
towards
um that model's results so you can kind
of think as like a nested data frame
but it's just flattened out and in that
case it's pretty nice
um so right there makes it so we did a
lot of this pre-rendered work
um beforehand and that way it'll make
our our uh
thing a little bit faster so right there
um it'll speed up our our stuff
a few things we should also consider is
that
when we run this app again let's run it
um
we kind of have to think about you know
what are people going to be
doing for our dashboard or how we're
going to how are users going to be
interacting with these filters
so for example this k slider it's
in scales of 1 and realistically we
don't think we're not going to think
that hey
changing a k value from 40 to 41
it's not gonna do a lot right
so instead of allowing the user to be
able to do all this complex stuff
we want to kind of like simplify the the
experience and simplify the usage
uh so that way um we have like less
complications
so what we can look at is maybe thinking
about changing
you know and the slider input from uh
1 to 100 and a value of 20 we can kind
of specify
essentially like the increments of it so
if we do that we know that
the shiny has the slider input
and what we can do is basically adjust
the step
to match essentially a a
larger increment value so that way
they're essentially like kind of like in
in increments of like 20. um so that way
it's a little bit easier and it makes
more sense for the user because
you know we don't really need that
granularity in the actual dashboard
okay so uh we don't need to save that
so we can run this again and we can kind
of go over here
right and we can also look at this how
um again
if you look at my previous video about
you know reactive variables i didn't do
it for this model
and in this case the elo model is
extremely fast it's essentially like a
linear time model
right because it's just assessing the
the two scores with the formula
um you don't even have to run it as an
evo model you can just calculate the
formula by hand
in r which is vectorized so in this case
it's super fast right you know you can
do it essentially in real time
predictions
but you know if we're running maybe you
know like an svm model
um we might not want the model to be
called every time we just move this
slider instead we would want
a button to say okay we're going to
adjust this parameter
we're going to choose these fighters
we're going to choose these weight
classes or whatever
and then we're going to run the model to
get the actual probability
okay so that's also an idea that we can
do
um additionally what we can think about
is how we can look at these plots
um i'm sorry i don't know why i'm always
uh doing that
so when we're creating a bunch of these
plots we also have to think about
you know what how many pots actually
need some type of filtering
right um not every plot needs a crazy
specific filter um even though when you
think about it like oh hey we're
filtering data that means it'll be
easier for the model
for the plus to render out but um adding
all these filterings
towards every plot um by just like
changing one thing so if we just change
it to like
flyweight it's going to change all these
things um we kind of have to think about
like how useful are these global filters
for our dashboard you know
we might want to consider you know some
charts where we don't need a filter on
it
um obviously for this use case i think
it's pretty useful to see the filtering
but you know maybe for weight class it
might not be as necessary
right just to view the distributions of
it or or whatever
os for the table would be necessary and
maybe even the time series it might be
necessary but
you know just just these considerations
of essentially simplifying
the dashboard um will be better for
the actual render times for your um
dashboard development
additionally just thinking about
dashboards as an actual
product that end users will be obviously
utilizing
you know you you kind of want to um kind
of want to uh
direct them towards how to use it and
kind of reduce the amount of
complexity to the actual dashboard
okay so this is the slow app or the
old app that i have um and then i
basically created a fast app
and i'm gonna actually kind of go over
some things that i changed with it
so one we have this pre-rendered evo
data that has
all of the elo model runs for each
increment
i also have the uh steps for that
um and additionally what i also have is
since we're always kind of using
the same um
since right here we're using the same
data set right create elo data create
elo data
you know we're calling the same data
instead of doing that we can kind of
put this into a reactive variable
do the filtering and then just call this
thing so that way we have
one you know a pre-computed data set two
uh it's kind of like stored as a global
variable so when it's already filtered
we only have to filter it again
when we're calling it and lastly
we can actually do some caching um so
caching is probably like the last thing
i
i think you should consider doing
because it can drastically improve
your actual performance of your
dashboard um so
when you're caching it you're
essentially you know saving that in
memory so
it's saying like okay this elo data is
from these type of inputs
so for reactive stuff you have to say
buy an event and then pass in
whatever um thing that you're filtering
off of since this is a reactive variable
we do by an event
and since we're also filtering using
these two filter
variables so our k variable and our
weight cost variable
it'll essentially save that kind of data
in its memory and kind of recall it
as is again i'm doing the same thing for
the second pages thing
um i also have a event reactive
so let's run this fast app and see this
so in this case we have a a predict
button
so we can click that uh we can change
the weight costs
uh and stuff we can so we can do like a
woman's women's bantamweight
uh we're going to choose these fighters
choose a specific elo
right and then predict it stuff like
that so right there um we can actually
switch this model out
uh instead of just like a generic elo
model we could switch it to like
an svm a nearest neighbor model or
something like that
um so with bind event we can basically
save those results
in memory and it can kind of recall the
the actual dashboard can recall it
um so with these like weight selectors i
didn't think it's really
necessary to do that um but when we go
to our actual plots so right here we
have bind
cache so instead of using the reactive
variables and we're actually
explicitly using these render plot
objects
we should be using bind cache instead so
with bind cache
again we're still saving the weight cost
and and k value
um so that way it will say okay we used
um
this weight class with this k value for
this plot so if we go back to that um k
k value and weight class it'll
essentially uh just
take it from memory instead of
re-rendering out the plot
so you can see it can get much faster
okay um one other thing that we should
also think about
and something that i especially when i
do these these type of videos when i'm
doing like
live r shiny development is that you
should also consider
using um bass r functions right
um so in this case right we have uh now
let me find here
we have this thing where it's like you
know
it's selecting the fighter doing the
distinct and the arrange
and then the choices is the the fighter
selector um the the actual fighters are
in that
in that weight class but um we can also
do it as a base our function right here
so um it's just calling eo data i'm
using
the actual explicit like row level index
using the which function
and saying um which fighter in this data
set is equal to v
fighter and then this is not equal to
the v fighter so we're trying to
you know take out the fighter from there
and then selects the actual fighter
as well as the uh as a list we
unique it out so we remove a lot of
duplicates and then we sort it
so one of this is probably a little bit
faster than this
but one of the issues we also think
about is like code readability and stuff
like that
so maybe we might even put this into a
little function and just say like
filter fighter stuff like that but
that's kind of when the problems with
r in general is that the code isn't as
readable as other languages
specifically like python but you should
also consider using base r functions
whenever you can
that being said there are some weird
quirks with bass r
and the tidy verse how you know when
you're using for loops
versus you know mapping functions i
believe like mapping functions are
actually
slightly faster than a forward in some
in most cases
so you never know but if if you really
need to you know test
some type of function out consider using
base r functions
if you have the chance okay
um so let's actually go and look at this
app
and we can see here we have this we have
the increments
it'll filter that out i'll filter that
out and as you can see it's a little bit
faster because it can do that
but as you can see once we do that once
we kind of already ran these filters
right it'll just be pretty much like
instantaneous right
so that's a cool way to do it
um again head to head we have the weight
class you know i guess
predict that um if we can go there
predict that
right um so again it's
it's almost once you have someone really
using it it'll get faster because it'll
kind of store it in memory
um so you also might be cons like asking
like hey
if i have so many users um working on
this and i'm
on my caching all these plots and and
reactive variables what about like
memory issues
um that is a problem and it's something
where
it's definitely on a use you like a use
case uh where
there are ways to basically manage the
cache
memory and limit it additionally you can
kind of like
go through and save and save the actual
cache files
and upload it so that way it'll have
like honestly like a pre-rendered out
pre-loaded like plots and stuff like
that
so i know this video was actually really
quick um there's only like a 16 minute
video but
um these are just some very quick ways
to improve
uh your your dashboard speed um without
going
into anything crazy there are some
um packages so um shiny
where you can do the uh um
what's it called the uh let me pull it
up shiny
um
where we can actually look at um
uh ways to basically make it faster by
uh
essentially simulations um so let me let
me find
this
with uh right here so
the the uh where is it
profiling where's the uh what's the
actual package name
use caching memoize
um but there are ways where we can
basically uh
pull up the actual um our shiny stuff
let me
find it um our shiny
[Music]
shiny
right here okay let's see
um shiny dashboard let's speed
it where is it
um
let's see oops
well i guess i can't really find it
right now but there are there are
different um packages too
that can make it a little bit faster um
let me i want to i want to find it what
are the uh
maybe it's from here
actually how do i
wait i i have the package
packages and then uh tiny
shiny load test so we can also look at
shiny load test
um that's what it's called um and the
reason why
i didn't want to go over shiny load test
is it requires
a few installations that i think is a
little bit
too out of the scope of you know
beginner dashboarding
but um if you're trying to do actually
production level
shiny dashboards um this is a good way
to basically analyze
um what are your bottlenecks for all of
your dashboard
um you know all the things that are in
the back
back end for your dashboard so you can
actually like install
essentially the shiny dash uh the shiny
load test package
but you're also gonna have to install
this java file and run run it through
there
but after you have all that stuff
installed you can basically run a
command line function that will
basically kind of go through
your dashboard and figure out where it's
really slow at
and that's a good way to basically
identify the things that you want to
work on
um and and fix uh so you can make your
dashboards a little bit faster
okay so with that being said um that's
the conclusion of this
shiny series i have a few more videos i
want to um basically record
specifically on the grammar of graphics
i also want
to do a short video on you know just r
studios functionality
and project development and workflows so
i'm pretty excited to do those videos
um and i'll see you guys next time so
tidy on